hello the Internet I'm GAF I'm Dan
we're the slow mo guys and for this
video we were lucky enough to be given a
car by BMW yeah choose BMW this is a 2
Series convertible BMW so it's pretty
nippy I mean I was playing around with
it earlier I was getting some
I was getting pretty fast because this
is a convertible it's been designed in a
very aerodynamic way as the car drives
the air flows over the top of the car
and hopefully in the rain prevents
everyone inside from getting wet
so for this video we're going to be
testing exactly that we set up some fake
rain at the end of this road and that's
going to drive through it shall I give
it the beans full beans cool beans yeah
did they did this anything about wheel
spins or handbrake turns they did not it
didn't excellent
whoa
dan you absolutely rag dit I did give it
maximum beans on that what was the air
what was the experience was were we
doing about 100 and 110 millions a
hundred yeah yeah oh you did 60 no that
look like 60 miles an hour to you say
like that's a fast 60 I was got run over
by the wind [ __ ] maximum beans right so
yeah it's like I'm driving along and
then it's just this wall of water Mike
well and it just hits the car in like a
big sudden clap and and then I'm just
like to come out the other side that
well I'm perfectly dry so yeah it's
pretty cool because obviously the rains
coming down but because of the wind goes
so fast it like pushes it over the back
and keeps me dry but obviously I'm
trying to keep like a cool face be like
yeah it's fine no bother
but then yeah the slow mode determined
that to be alone but okay so now Dan
yeah I'm gonna get a shot I'm gonna be
behind you in the car sweet I think I
feel pretty cool it's because that's
where I am right now yeah yeah are you
gonna get like brain hit in the front
yeah how can I try and get it so I
tracked you and also see if we can see
some of the water coming over yeah when
a super wide lens is a 12 millimeter
lens which is why it looks like a bin
lid you ready yeah
ah let me see what you like doing this
so much
yeah such a great damn cool shot yeah
well then that works perfectly
we saw the trail of mist that the car
was just putting straight over everyone
in the car yeah that was really fun I
mean you had three people in the car
there no one got a drop of water on it's
like you just hit a wall of water and
it's just like wash yeah oh and you're
giving up some good beans there yeah
maximum maximum Oh beans big beans well
I hope you enjoyed that video be sure to
follow us on Twitter
bye t-shirt if you want we got three
shirts and subscribe to the slow mo guys
cool thanks for watching just at this
point is basically just rags yeah I'm
just doing up getting you a new one oh
man you gotta take care of your uniform
two holes in it